alors on me demandait sur la
présentation des chroniqueurs je vais
commencer capillaire de la téloche j'en
ai jamais matthieu delormeau
voilà alors la classe de questions les
oreilles que j'en ai dans les couilles
[Rires]
et pour terminer celui sans qui on qu'on
va faire cette émission et pourtant je
préférerais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est particulier mais la question
seconde réponse kelly agathe valérie
isabelle kelly agathe valérie isabelle
duault mythe cherchez l'intrus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mes fans me réclame toujours mon
imitation de jean marc allaire à 6,5 me
trouvais content mais je t'emmerde
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez des rituels avant
une émission non non on fait un truc
voilà nombre que moi j'ai rien moi pour
taper mal ep mptp mp moi je merci grand
chose chacun une émission qui avait
aussi ses balances ton poste à berne
atteint semaine tu m'envoies des petits
messages et tout j'adore on va des fois
je je hurle devant ma télé parce que
j'ai envie d'intervenir c'est pas c'est
passionnant merci et je n'ai pas
beaucoup de coups de savoir quand et des
pmp au ballon ce temps passait plus rien
n'avait pas quoi le singe les fans pour
devrait sûrement jean-marc takuto et
munitions pour en parler
mach est ce que tu peux nous va être
beau d'imitation alors demande s'il te
plaît fermez le coeur de sortir la
baisse que tu peux sortir la nuit
ça lui est d'une beauté bienvenue dans
touche pas abu al aboudi ce soir une
émission 100% d'arca et zéro hora sera
combatif et douvres à l'achat le concept
vous connaissez des chroniqueurs qui
font semblant d'avoir des trucs à dire
qu'ils vont faire semblant d'avoir vu
des émissions et quoi qu'il arrive ils
vont les défoncer et ce soir je vous le
dis mais chez les chroniqueurs soit faut
maintenant c'est que comme ils regardent
des films porno où les femmes sont
toujours constamment épiée ça comme tu
vois effectivement là la tâche a comme
vous dites ce que vous avez une vérité à
me dire tard
capricieux excessif boudeur mauvais
joueur autoritaire revue
nos missions de qualité beaucoup de gens
disent on veut voir la séquence du
détecteur de mon chien je détecte le
mensonge
grâce à la voix est ce que on entend
beaucoup de ces derniers temps est ce
que vous vous rapprochez de plus en plus
du groupe m6 ou w9 est ce que j'allais
manger
ah ben c'est une vraie question moi
c'est la direction écrire
sinon est-ce que si vous allez dans le
groupe m6 vous partirez avec l'équipe
pas tous oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
si l'école est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
neuf cent mille combien j'hébergeais de
pension alimentaire depuis mai dimanche
combien seront-ils par semaine alcool et
courses poursuites n'est pas que fait
benjamin castaldi vous en faites sur
quoi le ministre de la justice voudrait
appuyé attendait initialement très
bonnes réponses le niveau du fisc c'est
ça surtout une rapide et très
prochainement non c'est ça c'est de la
merde en boite
[Rires]